24 months of eating [ __ ] to be able to
eat caviar for the rest of your life
microwave mom doesn't doesn't gotta
graduate
come back on Idol like a visible an
absolute clarity muscle my my name is
Jerry Saba [ __ ] I've been
telling you how to talk about yeah I'll
triple together the pedigree to beat in
a pleasure my specialty according to
work and I'm jernard the moving
furniture after yo what up everyone
saturday looks good really appreciate
all of you thank you so so much for all
the love they say Levy's all about my
science playas good friend jet friend my
brother alex is good friend from post
college we became super friendly he was
a ticket business kinda came work a
[ __ ] where you're actually a something
most people don't know about later
choice open mike was a pompous expert
conceited Yahoo doesn't like to talk
about Vader cause I don't like about
failures what will tell the story about
Boehner toys actually in a different
episode maybe I'll do it today when I
walk but now is crushing him we're just
talking about his next chapter and
giving Ben cheek line or shadow all
about Hamilton poke
networking life advice a youngster is
always part of the equation on a random
Saturday so two good things number one
this tweet about eating [ __ ] went out
and caught a lot of people's attention
and thought of expand on it
I just am surprised by how many of you
don't realize that the leverage in the
world is always the thing that is less
obvious to the masses meaning giving is
a better strategy than taking over the
long-term so I'm just going to give as
much as I can on this channel and then
eventually one day somehow you might owe
me a favor eating [ __ ] and taking it and
being the bigger man and woman in every
situation which is my which is really my
definition of eating [ __ ] is something I
do every day every day 95% of the time I
have the leverage but I don't use it and
to me that is leadership to me that's
playing the long game to me that's
building relationship to me that's
building confidence to me that's how a
million different things that um that I
think a lot of people misunderstand and
is the thing that really separates the
winners from the losers in my opinion in
society because I think it's super easy
to throw around your your big stick at
every moment but I think eventually you
you run out of pay makers you become a
weird version of the boy that cries wolf
and so for me I'm pretty passionate
about really focusing on um eating [ __ ]
on looking at the comments and laughing
them off on allowing my managers to get
away with something this time just a lot
of versions of it it's actually so kind
of hardwired in me it's very similar to
the customer's always right just
deploying enormous empathy
I just eat [ __ ] constantly I love
watching people thinking they're getting
away with it
but they're just creating a check marks
in the lost column that I'll eventually
expose or use or act on or not I mean my
preferences I never have to act on it
and and I can play that 5149 now Boehner
sports
that back in that realm when the
hurricane came here in New York back in
the day Mike he saw earlier I was trying
to convince him to leave his job because
I've got to get a lot more talent and as
a middle move
I created a business called leaner toys
and mighty just said sports by the way
being her toys and him and Lou who works
at vaynermedia now and a friend that I
grew up some baseball cards with Lee
Platt and a cousin of mine Sean Garelick
and ultimately that was the model issue
right and hit the button there Blackson
ultimately that was the the issue with
the business there was too much overhead
against the strategy but it was
basically Boehner toys was the 2017 eBay
flip change I have this really
interesting 2017 challenge it is my
belief that everybody has a ton of
tchotchkes we're going to 20,000 20,000
$170 challenge could we create a side
business that could make hundreds of
thousands of dollars by buying and
selling stuff from thrift stores garage
sales you know junk auctions the answer
is the revenue was there I created too
much old infrastructure because I was
trying to really build a team around a
lot of my homies and and so the dollars
were there but I treated it too much
like a like a like a hobby business I
treated it too much like a place to put
a bunch of my friends and cousins and
relatives and relationships and
ultimately we were just losing money
there was no reason to do it but I
absolutely believe and especially since
I've seen what's going on now it it
empowered me to very much believe that
there was 30 40 50 60 70 80 90 thousand
dollars a year in profit to be made if
he took this seriously and what I love
about life is I really focus on every
negative becoming a positive and going
through that confirming what AJ and I
were doing by seeing what Vayner toys
short six months look like confirmed and
gave me the audacity to create the 2017
flip challenge that hundreds of you
thousands of you are going to be
impacted on I cannot wait for the end of
this year to watch all the people who
bought homes paid off loans bought a car
we're not a family vacation all because
of a piece of content I created
and that makes me super happy oh and a
quick PS a little clip from two years
ago on an askgaryvee instagrams game is
really fascinating to me
betting hard on it all of you
entrepreneurs should a little ramp a hat
about Instagram it's been fun to see
that play out it is the number one
social network as the attention graph
goes by the way I need to definitely
make an attention graph like like we got
to get into like that because that's
what I care about over time and and
that's one of the great things about
documenting all this being able to do
these fun recalls two years ago if you
were on this train if you were paying
attention you might have gone deep into
the Instagram game that I'm trying to
really focus a lot of you guys on and
and I'm really that's my biggest
number-one like I'm going to give out
the value and I hope you act on it see
you tomorrow
[Music]